House and Senate Republicans are ready
to end the year with a big gift for
President Trump they reached a tax
reform compromise yesterday combining
the House and Senate bills that would
cut taxes by more than 1.4 trillion
dollars over a decade now the GOP wants
to keep a promise to send a final bill
to the White House by Christmas
Democrats claim the new version is even
more slanted toward the wealthy the bill
also changes the affordable care act and
preserves most deductions for medical
expenses student loan interest and state
and local taxes Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill with the numbers from the
House and Senate deal Nancy good morning
good morning House and Senate
Republicans say they've been working
hard and they have reached an agreement
in principle that combines these two
bills all that's left to do they say is
to put that combined bill into
legislative language they insist they
are still on track to pass this bill in
the House and Senate next Monday and
Tuesday enabling the president to keep a
promise he repeated yesterday we want to
give you the American people a giant tax
cut for Christmas the president
celebrated his party's quick work
melding two very different tax plans
the combined bill would eliminate Obama
cares health insurance mandate double
the standard deduction for individuals
and married couples and allow tax payers
to deduct a combined ten thousand
dollars from state and local income
taxes and property taxes it would also
lower individual tax rates bringing the
top rate down from thirty nine point six
percent to thirty seven percent only the
top one percent will benefit from that
change Democrats argue the biggest
benefits still go to the wealthy and to
corporations which would see their tax
rates drop from 35 percent to as low as
21 percent Republicans say that what
they learned from the Alabama race was
is that they need to get things done to
show the American people that they can
govern when they say they need to get
something done it's as if you have a
sick patient and instead of curing him
you chop off their right arm and say
we're getting something done patient
isn't gonna like it too much that's
regular order report
all due respect that is regular order
senator you're out of order but in a
contentious bipartisan tax conference
Wednesday Republicans insisted that
under their plan
nearly everyone will pay less at least
in the short term it reduces tax rates
for all Americans of all walks of life
and they said an overhaul of this
magnitude is long overdue
we weren't called here just to make a
few tweaks around the edges to make a
few changes we were called here today to
make sure that our tax code is fixed
forever congressional sources tell CBS
News that they expect to get a final
analysis from the Joint Committee on
taxation a bipartisan congressional
group by Friday looking at the costs and
benefits of their new and apparently
final plan they also say Gail that they
have been checking in with their
potential holdouts throughout this
process and they believe they're gonna
stick with them all right Nancy the
discussion will continue on that thank
you very much